what a beautiful evening it is here by
this lake [ __ ] my first duck of the
spring it's a great time of the year
lakes are starting to break up Ducks are
starting to come back
grayling coming up the creek had a great
day out here took a lot of time to get
this duck
put a shot one sooner but I want to make
sure that I could recover and that was
the thing that water's real cold and I
don't know how deep this lake is but it
looks like it falls off pretty steep
right after you leave sure so I didn't
want to take a chance I have a dumb plan
further out there or blow further out
there and not be able to recover it yeah
sometimes you hit a duck and then it
lands right on the ice if it's in the
air or sometimes you'll hit a duck and
it'll be alive for a little while and
they'll start swimming and they'll swim
right out off of shore and you can't get
to us he got to be careful you got to
pick your shots if you don't want to
lose ducks you got to make sure that you
wait for the right moment when that
moment comes you got seize the
opportunity I was just watching this
duck for a long time and I saw it was
getting in close to shore it wasn't
gonna go anywhere it was ice behind it
wasn't gonna go swimming out just
waiting for the right moment
took a shot
all that ducks Matt tastes good
it's really just about seeing what's
going on keeping track of the animals
keeping track of the plants and change
of the seasons
that's what I wanted to do today get out
and take a look at springtime because I
hadn't really seen it yeah it just came
on so suddenly got myself a duck had a
hell of a good time